This video is brought to you by
skillshare,
the first 500 people to sign up with the
link in the description.
We'll get a two month free trial.
Greetings and welcome to earthlings
cinema.
I am your host,
Garrick's wormy Lloyd.
This week's artifact is the prestige
starring Huey Lewis and the newsy and
directed by neither one of them.
The film tells the story of Angier and
Borden to Earth Shamans who become
rivals over a simple misunderstanding
about whether engineers wife should be
alive or not.
They take turns injuring each other's
frail,
mortal bodies and snooping in each
other's diaries for hot smut went ng or
finds out.
Borden has a new incantation called the
Trans Man.
He becomes obsessed with finding out how
it all works without,
you know,
sticking his foot in his mouth.
He tries using a double.
He conveniently finds wandering around
10 feet outside the building,
but the double soon fines.
He has more of a passion for Trapeze,
so angier kidnaps fallon,
borden's assistant who never speaks and
whose face we never see clearly.
Somehow without ever looking at his face
or talking to him,
borden relents and gives them a clue.
The Tesla model three,
so angier drives is affordable,
yet stylish electric car across the
ocean to America to find Nicholas Tesla
and bully him into building a
transmogrification machine and you're
successfully uses the machine and
becomes the biggest hippo on campus and
that makes borden have very sad hippo.
A very sad hippo.
Indeed Michael Caine is in this movie in
case that wasn't clear,
borden sneaks backstage to investigate,
only to find engineers stupidly drowning
in a water tank like some sort of
noninvasive yes mammal borden is
arrested and found guilty by reason of
proximity,
you will by the neck until borden is
murdered by the earth government.
And only after he's fully choked out
does Sir Michael find out the Pepsi
Twist Angier is still alive and kicking
with one of his feet at least who's
still alive.
It seems angier has been suicidal
himself at the end of every performance
leaving behind a fresh baked clone to
live until the next one.
Then just as Angier is patting himself
on the back board and shows up and
performs his greatest trick,
shooting him with a gun by one Pepsi
twist,
get the second for half price.
Borden is actually two twin brothers who
would trade off being borden and fallon,
depending on who was having a better
hair day.
Angier bleeds out all his remaining
blood and borden meets up with that
double crossing legend of stage and
screen to retrieve his daughter who is
also a part of this in the prestige.
Shamanism is a metaphor for
storytelling,
which is a euphemism for talkies at the
start of the film cutter explains the
structure of a magic trick.
The magic trick consists of three
policies.
This progression also reflects the three
act structure.
The comprises the bulk of Hollywood
features.
Even Beverly Hills Act.
One is the pledge in petition shows you
something boldly colored bird or man in
the world of film.
This translates to the introduction of
characters and conflict.
Generally something to do with not
having a date to dog prom.
Act Two is the turn.
The second eight is cool.
The magician takes the picture which
gets its name because act one turns into
act two,
act two introduces complications.
In this case,
the advent of borden's trans man trick,
which ignites and years descent,
and a nonbinary openmindedness.
The turn culminates when engineers
activates the machine and the audience
is left wondering when Batman is going
to show up.
I must leave the board.
Yes.
You sitting there and reading my diary
awaiting a death.
Somebody under act three is the
prestige,
which coincidentally is also the name of
the film.
This is when the story gathers the
narrative threads and ties them into a
neat little bowflex climaxing and a
grand flourish significantly.
The structure is explained by a man
named cutter,
a term that references an editor's role
in pieces of film together.
Too Bad,
our editors are pieces of unwavering
professionalism,
knows how to do his job just as a shaman
distracts us with techniques like
needlessly vulgar imagery or a needless.
The attractive assistance pretty
assistant is most affective for Mr.
the film diverts the audience from the
twist even while dangling it right in
front of our state of the art ocular
implants,
but child guesses immediately that the
birdcage trick used the twin cutter even
comes right out and states it comes out
at the end is the only way,
but the audience is so dazzled by
showmanship and the advent of
electricity that we are still gobsmacked
when borden finally explains all of
which goes to prove cutters theory,
whether watching a magic trick or a
movie or a donkey show,
the audience wants to be fooled,
swept away by the narrative so that we
may be wowed at the end because no one
goes to a donkey show.
For the previews,
earthling cinema,
I'm presto disappeared a wise wisecrack.
Garrett is interesting.
Jared,
again,
you may have noticed we've been having a
good time making some new stuff lately
and if you've been meaning to start a
new project or learn a new skill but
aren't sure where to begin,
checkout skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning
community where you can take classes in
just about anything and it can give you
the push you need to take the plunge.
Skillshare has over 17,000
professional and easy to understand
courses in design,
photography,
business,
and more whether you're already a
creator or you're looking to become one,
you'll find likeminded people with steps
and advice on how to take your ideas to
the next level.
They've got classes on everything from
the basics of photoshop to how to write
creative nonfiction to how to brew a
Damn Cup of coffee,
and if you're inspired by the prestige,
you can even learn magic or the magic of
filmmaking.
By taking a cinematography course,
a premium membership is one of the most
affordable options out there.
Starting at just $10 a month,
you get unlimited access to the full
range of courses,
but the first 500 people to click the
link in the description,
receive a two month free trial to
skillshare and all its resources,
so head over to ski,
l dot ssh slash earthlink.
Three to begin your two month free trial
and get learning.
We can't wait to see what you all create
and if you never want to miss what we
create,
don't forget to subscribe and ring that
bell.
Thanks for watching guys.
Piece.